now to an incident involving actress and
director olivia wilde wilde was on stage
at a movie convention in las vegas on
tuesday when someone slid a yellow
envelope to her while she was talking
about her new movie the envelope was
labeled personal and confidential
according to reports she was being
served child custody documents from
ex-fiance jason sudeikis hey wild did
not give any indication of what the
envelope contained and she just carried
on with her remarks sudeikis reportedly
had no prior knowledge that wilde would
be served with the papers during her
appearance at cinemacon while in cidacas
they have two children cinemacon said it
would reevaluate its security protocols
so far no comments from weil's
representatives it does raise all sorts
of questions how somebody could get that
closer on the stage exactly even get
into the space because you usually need
wristbands you need you know a little
lanyard and then not only to get in okay
that's one thing but then to approach
the stage yeah and hand someone into an
envelope i do not believe jason's today
i don't did that on purpose i don't
think he's not believing the reports are
that he used a process server company
and he had no he would have a lawyer he
would have a legal team and then the
lawyers would hire the process servers
and they do what they do
he doesn't strike me as somebody who
would play that i don't think so no no i
don't know it's an ugly scene but it was
an awkward moment for her hope they work
it out overall we do yeah me too